monstre sacré du rock français champion
des ventes de disques et des tournées
triomphales johnny hallyday c'était
d'abord un look un son est bien sûr une
gueule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa carrière prend son envol en 1960 le
jeune adolescent de 17 ans originaire
d'une famille d'artistes de cirque rêves
de gloire et de rock'n roll ses premiers
succès misé sur son image de tombeur et
s'inspire de ses idoles américaine
l'avenir est dans ma famille
dans les premières années de sa carrière
il présente des spectacles au québec ici
comme en france les jeunes l'adorent
quelques d'avancé du spectacle j'en ai
envie mais je très bon le meilleur cash
et jérôme g des monnaies mondiales ont
dû dès les années soixante et soixante
dix neuf heures ont trôné au sommet des
palmarès en france pendant ses
spectacles
on assiste à des émeutes à des scènes
d'hystérie il devient une icône il est
sacré idole des jeunes puis roi du rock
[Musique]
amoureux du rock il sauve tout de même
sur tous les styles
s'adaptant aux modes et devenant au fil
du temps et des décennies un
incontournable de la culture populaire
francophone
johnny hallyday a enregistré plus de
1000 chansons vendu 60 millions d'albums
en carrière et fait une centaine de
tournée même s'il est une méga star dans
la francophonie
son succès ne traversera pourtant jamais
les frontières avec ses tics son style
et ses influences américaines
il reste une exception culturelle
française tout en consacrant sa vie à la
musique
il mène en parallèle une discrète
carrière d'acteur aussi débridé qu'il
puisse être sur scène il surprend au
cinéma par un jeu retenue et tout en
nuances dans le film jean philippe
en 2005 il est interprète johnny
hallyday devenu garagiste plutôt qu'à
rock star mais il est jamais trop
d'impôts accomplir son destin le vôtre
le vôtre c'est d'être johnny hallyday
chante et pour les gens de leur donner
du bonheur
alors que dans les années 2000 il est en
voie de devenir le papy du rock français
il fonde une nouvelle famille déjà père
de deux enfants adultes
il adopte deux filles avec sa dernière
épouse laeticia de 32 ans sa cadette
sausset
à la même époque il multiplie les duos
les chanteuses québécoises avoir fait
évidemment partie de ses partenaires
favorite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à 66 ans en 2009 l'euro carré camp des
saints annonce qu'il ne veut pas devenir
pathétique au zouk son public
il entame une grande tournée d'adieu
tour 66 et subi parallèlement plusieurs
opérations pour un cancer du côlon et
une hernie discale
mais la plus grande star de l'hexagone
n'allait pas s'arrêter là en 2012
il repart à nouveau en tournée avec le
spectacle jamais seul qu'il viendra
présenter sur les plaines d'abraham au
festival d'été de québec
énergique guitare au cou et moulée de
cuir noir il sera resté jusqu'à la fin
le rockeur qu'il a toujours rêvé d'aller
le bras du canada montréal
[Musique]